hi i'm joey santor plant lover botanist
and working class mooc today i'm here to
answer your plant questions via twitter
this is plant support
[Music]
okay this one's from cash smart llc
maybe maybe this guy could do my taxes
when we're done is it possible for
humans to have a symbiotic relationship
with a plant species it happens all the
time you know there are plants who've
had enormous increases in their
distribution due to human beings
cannabis is a great example of that
cannabis now occurs on every continent
except antarctica that's a great example
of of humans taking a plant increasing
its range increasing its genetic
diversity many domestic crop species
many of the plants we eat and even
invasive weeds that tend to thrive in uh
areas of human disturbance a great
example of that would be something like
tree of heaven atlantis altissima really
thrives in our cities it can tolerate
pollution it can tolerate drought it can
tolerate growing out of concrete and it
spreads by rhizomes so that's a great
example uh the tree of heaven has
benefited extensively from uh its
association with human society
okay this one's from uh dylan choli how
the [ __ ] does mulch work if i was a
smart ass i would just say you know you
get a couple guys throwing logs and a
wood chipper and then out comes all the
wood chips but the the benefit of mulch
like why you throw it in a garden is
because not only does it protect that
bearing soil from transpiration of water
from losing all its moisture from
getting heated up by the sun but also
once it rains and that mulch gets some
moisture fungi and microbes break it
down and then add a bounty of nutrients
to the soil that is then accessible to
all the plants that grow in it so it
helps retain moisture it adds nutrients
and also it keeps other weeds down that
might compete with the plants that you
want to have in that garden this one
from typhoon annie how tf can you over
water a plant like
just don't drink it little dude well
typhoon it doesn't really work like that
see a lot of plants depending on where
they grow and cacti are a great example
of this their roots soak up water like a
dry sponge now this works for them
because where they grow it's often very
dry and it's often very hot so when
moisture does seep into that soil it
evaporates pretty quickly due to the
heat you know you water a cactus in the
winter it's going to sit in that soil
for uh you know upwards of a few days
before it evaporates and in doing so
it's it's only able to soak up so much
based on the metabolism that it's going
the metabolic rate of course is
dependent on the temperature so if it's
too chilly it's just gonna sit in that
water and it can't access the water it's
already full and at that point it begins
to rot this one's from uh melissa eileen
wtf is an orchid the word doesn't sit
right with me orchid sounds like a lot
of hoopla drunk mel okay well although i
am against drunk tweeting i do have to
agree with you the word doesn't sit
right with you because uh it's the greek
word for testicle the reason the greeks
named
orchids after orcas the greek word for
testicle is because in europe most of
the terrestrial orchids do indeed have a
little tuber that kind of looks like a
nut this one's coming from at jackson
rice do you have any idea how long it
takes to grow peyote and here's a nice
picture we've provided with the
beautiful pink flower of a lofapara
williamseye how peyote grows in
cultivation is entirely dependent on the
warmth that's provided for it get a
little seedling heat mat get the plant's
metabolism going remember plant
metabolism is entirely dependent on
temperature almost you have the right
kind of warmth you get the right soil
you know you can grow a seed to a golf
ball sized little button in upwards of
four or five years now jackson i i have
a feeling as to why you're asking this
question and you know it's probably has
something to do with ingesting this
plant and i don't blame you maybe you
want to have a vision quest you know you
want to have a little insight into
yourself i would tell you there's
probably easier ways to do it because
these plants take a long time to grow
and uh you gotta eat at least four or
five of them to get any effects so uh
would you really want to do that to a
plant that took you five years to grow
this is from uh
alex garrard alex with no eve that makes
any sense anthropos signed us a plant
taxonomy wtf even is that that's one of
my favorite subjects actually plant
taxonomy is the study of classifying
organisms and it might seem like it's a
bunch of latin names that some dead
european white guys made up you know 300
years ago what the does this matter now
but actually it's a pretty beautiful
system to organize things according to
how they evolve and if you start to
grasp this you can grasp how everything
is related now a good example of
binomial nomenclature in every binomial
name as genus and species homo sapiens
would be a great example of this a good
botanical example is this guy right here
this is clystocactus cola de mononus and
it used to be in the genus hildewentaria
until dna sequencing was done on it
botanists realized that it was actually
shared the same dna sequences as a genus
that already existed called
kleistocactus so chrysler cactus coladae
menonas now you can also go by the
common name monkey's tail but there's
probably quite a few other cacti that go
by the common name monkey's tail so if
you call it monkey's tail
it's kind of hard to know which one
you're talking about if you're looking
for specificity
this one is from uk ed video what's the
strangest plant in the world it's a good
question and i have to give it to a
plant called well witchy and mirabilis
that grows in the fog deserts of namibia
now it's a very old lineage of plant
it's so old that fossils of it occur in
south america before it had all that
tectonic action that hot tectonic action
split them apart and created the
atlantic ocean so this is an old lineage
of plant but it's a bizarre looking
weirdo too can live for a thousand or
two thousand years it's more closely
related to conifers like redwoods than
it is to uh flowering plants of course
which evolved later and uh it has the
same two leaves throughout its entire
life they grow in very barren dry areas
and most of their moisture does indeed
come from fog off those cold ocean
currents to the west
all right this one's coming from uh
icari mushrooms are an example of
something i hate because i don't
understand lol like how do they grow how
are they so resilient why do we eat
fungi this [ __ ] will really worth you
out fungi are actually more closely
related to us than they are to plants
you go far enough back in the uh tree of
life you'll see that it branched off
within the last billion years but pretty
far back what you see when you see a
mushroom is just in essence the fruit of
the fungus it doesn't hurt the fungus
itself to pick the mushroom if you could
anthropomorphize a lot of fungi would
prefer to have their mushrooms picked
because that's how they end up
dispersing their spores around but the
fungus itself the living organism
actually consists of these things called
mycelial strands a mycelium looks like
this white webby material that basically
spreads into a substrate whether it's a
rotting log or the soil and looks for
things to eat and the way it eats them
is by secreting enzymes that in effect
break down cellulose or lignin or in
some cases human tissue to uh extract
nutrients from them and this one's from
botany rng what's your most interesting
plant fact for me what got me really
excited about learning this when i first
did was that geology
in some cases directly affects plant
growth you get certain plants that occur
only on a certain type of rock you know
whether you get gypsum in the chihuahua
desert or a limestone or in california a
very odd and somewhat toxic rock that
sometimes contains asbestos called
serpentanite there are plants that only
grow on that type of substrate you won't
find them growing anywhere else they
need the gypsum or they need the
serpentine or they need the limestone
and a great example of that is a plant
called funeral sage you'll never find
funeral sage growing anywhere else
except on limestone where there's often
almost no soil at all it's just growing
straight out of these porous limestone
rock and it produces very small purple
flowers and the leaves are so covered in
wool and fuzz that they look like pointy
q-tips all right this one's from kathy
casilda i learned that joshua trees are
naturally spread by giant sloths eating
the seeds and since there are no more
giant sloths the joshua tree habitat
hasn't changed is that true did i really
hear that it's kind of iffy there was a
paper that came out talking about this
about how joshua tree seeds were found
in giant sloth scat in a cave obviously
joshua trees are still around and giant
sloths aren't so something's going on
here some other animals dispersing the
seed turns out the animal that's most
responsible at present for dispersing
joshua tree seeds which just look like
little black flakes kind of like agave
seeds are rodents so there's rodents
that will take these fruits bring them
back to their little dens and homes
crack the fruits open and then cash the
seeds kind of stash them so they bury
them like a centimeter under the soil
but the thing is they don't remember
where they put all of them so they
forget sometimes and those end up
germinating and turning into new joshua
trees at one point the giant sloths were
probably doing a lot of the dispersing
but the yucca brevifolia the joshua
tree's not too picky rodents can do it
too or even in some cases humans this
one from yumiko jabami flowers have
ovaries yes indeed when you're eating a
fruit you're eating an ovary now an
ovary is just a kind of a vessel for the
seeds and what's it's what
differentiates flowering plants from
other plants like ferns and mosses and
conifers ovaries are part of uh the
compound sexual part aka the gynoesium
of a flower called a pistol pistol with
two eyes not at all kind of
counterintuitive so you've got the ovary
which is uh at the base of that pistol
and then you've got the style which is
the stalk that holds up the stigma and
the stigma is where the pollen lands so
from the top down it goes stigma style
ovary ovary being at the bottom and it's
actually a very important diagnostic
factor when you're trying to look at a
flower and figure out what genus or what
family it's in indeed flowers have
ovaries and when flowers get pollinated
they mature into a fruit and that's
exactly what a fruit is it's an ovary
now this is a nice question this is from
melanie restaurant can we please figure
out how to harvest and process the kudzu
that is killing trees here in america
kudzu is a member of the pea family for
basie that was brought over here from
asia it's taken over completely covers
trees smothers forests it thrives in the
american southeast and it's very hard to
control kudzu is causing a loss of
biodiversity in many of these forests
because nothing can out compete it kudzu
is almost at the top of the food chain
here's a nice example of it this
illustrates the problem with a lot of
invasive species and some people tend
not to believe that invasive species are
real you know a plant is a plant right
what does it matter where it came from
or what species it is just let it grow
but unfortunately it doesn't work like
that no species is an island species are
members of things called ecosystems and
they've evolved in those ecosystems for
millions of years developing a
relationship with all the insects and
fungi and other plants and animals in
that ecosystem and when you take a plant
out of one ecosystem and bring it say 4
000 miles across an ocean to another
ecosystem it ends up sometimes not
having anything to keep it in check so
the best we can do with kudzu right now
is give the native plants the native
species a fighting chance and just
remove it by hand all right this one's
from uh nordie pong mangroves help
stabilize the coastline by reducing
erosion caused by storms strong currents
waves and tides how the way mangroves
work is they've got these roots that
kind of act like a cage it looks like a
bunch of different curved pieces of
rebar that form kind of an impenetrable
thicket relatively close to the
shoreline so when these waves come in
you know you get a swell or a bad storm
or something they
hit these mangrove roots and uh the
mangrove roots break up that kinetic
energy of those waves thus protecting
the shoreline from further erosion this
one is from miss zoonosis why do leaves
change color in the fall and that's a
question we always we all used to ask as
kids the reason for that has to do with
different concentrations of pigments
that occur in the leaves now what we see
in a leaf is green that would be the
chlorophyll but there's also other
pigments present like carotenoids and
flavonoids which cause the yellow and
the orange color now as the winter
approaches and the daylight hours
decrease and the temperature decreases
that chlorophyll starts to break down
and uh basically degrade and as it does
that it reveals the yellows and the
oranges the carotenoids and the
flavonoids at the same time sugar
concentrations in the leaf are
increasing and as a result of that you
get the production of the red pigments
aka the anthocyanin pigments you know
you'd see in say a sugar maple leaf from
uh at the aaron m lambert can you cross
breed fruits like can someone work on a
pla mango or pineapple cot for me just
checking you can cross-breed fruits if
they're
closely enough related depends on how
back how far back in time uh these two
lineages diverged if they're in
different families no way but if they're
in the same genus you might you know
like prunus the genus of cherries you
might have luck with it now prunus is
the genus of cherries and almonds and
plums there's some wiggle room in there
you know you could get across a plum
with an apricot or plum with the cherry
but again it's got to be in the same
genus generally speaking okay this one's
nice this is from goco sweets i must run
a bakery or something also why are plant
medicines so taboo with four question
marks um it literally grows from the
ground we live on this planet earth the
same compound whether it's synthesized
in a lab or whether it is biosynthesized
in the tissues of a plant is no
different those two compounds are no
different from each other and often a
lot of the compounds we use in
pharmacology were actually first
identified in plants and then scientists
later learned to synthesize them which
was a more efficient way to produce
those compounds but some compounds we
still can't synthesize or it's just
easier to get them in the plant now the
term plant medicine can be a little uh a
little problematic sometimes because you
know cyanide is a naturally occurring
compound that you find in plants too as
is arsenic as are a number of other
highly toxic compounds so just because
it came from a plant and it came from
the earth that's not the best rationale
to get it remember that scene in
breaking bad where walter white extracts
ricin from a castor bean great example
of uh why we want to stay away from
using that rationale but indeed some
plants uh because of the compounds they
produce often to ward off fungi or
insects if those compounds are
bioavailable enough in the plant and
able to be utilized if they're ingested
or extracted then humans can use them
too and benefit from them and uh there's
there's some real truth to that but
people do get a little woo-woo about it
i've certainly seen it happen i mean you
really want to go down this wormhole
open up a [ __ ] organic chemistry
textbook you know rather than uh
watching some hippie snake oil salesmen
on youtube
all right moving right along next one we
got is from
jordan twitter plants loose what is this
cute little dude
uh they need some tlc but i can't figure
out what the type is help please well
normally when you're trying to identify
a plant you need a picture of a flower
reproductive structures whether it's
flowering plants or ferns or conifers
are
integral to diagnosing species because
you know leaves aren't really a good
classification system you know the same
genus can have
species with entirely different leaves
from one another but in this case i
already know this one uh and it's a
plant in the genus euphorbia and it
looks like it's from south africa it's a
stem succulent and it looks like it's
not getting enough light you got to get
this guy into a better well-lit window
or something the defining features of
succulents whether it's cacti or
euphorbias or crassulas or sedums or
whatever is that they're able to
basically store water so that's an
adaptive benefit in the dry climates
through which most of them have evolved
most succulents come from very arid
climates where water is in short supply
so they need to be able to suck up that
water quick and store it for later in
essence turning themselves into little
batteries that can weather the storm of
drought and heat perfectly this one's
coming from real life xo does anyone
know of any plants that can grow without
sunlight on any windows in my room
indeed there are quite a few plants that
can grow without sunlight one group of
them is known as mycoheterotrophs and
their plants that parasitize fungi you
got a lot of members of this group in
the blueberry family eric casey also
plants that parasitize other plants
oftentimes they don't need any sunlight
and they've entirely lost the ability to
produce chlorophyll at all there's no
green in them whatsoever and you can
tell these things when you find them in
a shady forest for instance because they
often occur in shades of white they're
pink but again there will be no green in
them whatsoever if you're looking for a
plant that can grow in an apartment
that's not that well lit there is an
answer for you though the best family of
plants that's most tolerant of uh human
living conditions i.e sometimes dry air
lack of water and lack of light is uh
members of the family eraser also known
as the airoids and again you'd be
looking at plants like monstera and
philodendron because these are plants
that in their native habitat they grow
in these really shady hot forests in the
tropics where it might rain a lot but
it's so hot that that the rain
evaporates pretty readily that moisture
evaporates pretty readily and so because
of that this family of plants is
tolerant of both poor light conditions
and poor moisture this one's coming from
han chappelle dick do plants need real
sunlight or does artificial light work
this might be why my dorm room plants
keep dying poor things no plants don't
need real sunlight all they need is the
right wavelengths that would be
wavelengths of the visible light
spectrum between the blue and the red of
course they're not utilizing the green
that's all they're reflecting back to us
but as long as he got blue and the red
in there and everything in between
except for the green they'll do fine you
know you can get that from a t5
fluorescent light you can get it from uh
sodium lights or even better yet if
you're trying to avoid a high energy
bill leds all right this one is from uh
silver sage witch how can you tell if a
plant is poisonous most poisonous plants
tend to have a very bitter smells to
them to the leaves bitter tasting
alkaloids another good way to tell if a
plant is poisonous is to know for
instance that most members of the
milkweed family also known as the
oleander family the apostolacy tend to
contain heart toxins called cardiac
glycosides so if you find a plant and
you know just from looking at the flower
that it's in the apostolacy the milkweed
family you know you probably don't want
to be putting it in your mouth any time
soon because you might die you know many
many plants that are poisonous a great
example is many members of nightshade
family will produce fruits that aren't
poisonous but to make it even more
confusing some of those species even the
same genus will produce fruits that are
poisonous so the same genus will produce
fruits that aren't poisonous like
tomatoes in the genus selenium and it
will also produce fruits like deadly
nightshade also in the genus selenium
that are poisonous so the best thing to
do is really just identify your plant
figure out what you're looking at they
got a number of apps that can do this
now and then just read up on it before
you go stuffing it in your mouth this
one's coming from cornell c-a-l-s why
does the corpse flower stink actually
that's a good question and it might
surprise you a lot of flowers produce
these putrid smells because what
pollinates them are beetles and flies
that would otherwise be eating carrion
aka corpses from wonderbot how do plants
breathe good question well you see
plants have these things called stomata
that are mostly on the undersides of
their leaves what they are is
microscopic pores through which carbon
dioxide gas goes in and oxygen and water
vapor go out like i said there are
generally more located on the undersides
of the leaves because this reduces
transpiration of moisture through said
pores okay this one
from basin my nine-year-old's question
at breakfast how do plants evolve if
they don't have a brain see this is what
we humans tend to do we tend to
anthropomorphize okay nothing really
intentionally evolves it's all just a
chance game of random mutations
interacting with the environment the
environment being geology climate
presence of herbivores etc so you know
you get genetic recombination i.e sex
pollen grain lands on a stigma
pollinates the ovary and then of course
the resulting seeds that you get in the
fruit have a somewhat different
phenotype than the parent plant a
phenotype is a set of observable
characteristics in a species and
sometimes within those resulting uh
seeds that germinate within those
resulting plants you get a random
mutations and those mutations can either
thrive or fail most of times they fail
but when they do thrive it's because
they generally have an adaptation that
benefits the resulting plant in the
environment all right next question from
mr cowman why are california's redwoods
and sequoias so big and tall so getting
big and tall is certainly an adaptive
benefit in a shady environment like a
forest that allows you to out-compete
other species of plants that might be
growing uh sympatrically or
occurring with you co-occurring with you
you know in the case of coast redwoods
that would be trees like oaks which
don't get very tall compared to redwoods
and in the case of giant sequoias it
would be plants like white furs and
ponderosa pines which again don't get
anywhere near as big or as tall as
redwoods so the adaptive benefit in
getting big is that you can out
out-compete your neighbors and also i'll
compete them not just for sunlight but
also for moisture that's available on
the ground all right next question and
this one's from ruth mkb question is
this some type of liking and it's a
picture of what appear to be
a cluster of shelf mushrooms growing on
what looks like a dead stump well ruth
you're close but not quite this is
actually a species of basidiomycin
fungus aka just a mushroom now
interesting enough what i'm liking is a
lichen is also a fungus but a lycan also
has two or three other organisms in
there you might have a cyanobacteria or
an algae doing the photosynthesis and
then of course you probably got a yeast
in there too obsidio might see east
lichens of course take a long time to
grow though and what a liking is it's a
great example of mutualism so
all the organisms in this arrangement
are standing to benefit they're all
living no one's really losing but they
don't like air pollution though so they
can't really grow in too many cities but
i was close maybe there's a like i'm
sure there's probably a liking on that
stuff too i just that's not what i see a
picture of from two nine swank i don't
know what that uh
kind of a weird name to each their own
how do i become a botanist now some
people think you got to go to school for
it schooling does help a more structured
environment can be very conducive to
learning the best thing to do to become
a bonus is just go to a botanic garden
or go out into even an empty lot start
taking pictures of plants we got these
phones in our pocket take pictures of
stuff you don't know what it is ask
questions imbibe yourself with curiosity
about the world download a plant
observation app like i naturalist then
uh every question you have will get you
an answer if you get and that answer
itself will open up 10 more questions
think about things think actively about
the things you see and observe learn
plant identification learn some plant
taxonomy and learn uh that flowers are
the ways in which we group plants
together in genus family order etc this
one's from uh demigod kid can you
interbreed or cross breed carnivorous
plants absolutely i got friends that do
it they run carnivorous plant nurseries
and some of the cultivars which is a
word for a phenotype that humans have
created some of these cultivars look
incredible unlike anything you'd find in
the wild you know you cross one species
of pitcher plant and the genus saracenia
with another species of pitcher plant
and a genus saracenia and you get some
wild [ __ ] that pops up you know all
different colors of pigmentation and
those pitcher leaves different kinds of
flowers etc okay this one's from mpi
simba what's the rarest plant there was
a plant i saw in the deserts of baja
california sir called uh in celia
densifolia i think there's only a
hundred plants in existence now is it a
neo-endemic i.e it evolved recently and
just has a restricted range or is it
what's called a paleo endemic it's a a
relic it basically evolved a long time
ago on the entire rest of its population
has been wiped out for whatever reason
climatic change or habitat loss or
whatever save for this little pocket
where it grows okay this one's coming
from uh taylor posting is there
something dangerous about durian why
does it smell bad now the smell in
durian is due to a sulfur compound you
know same thing you get coming out of a
gas station bathroom floor drain why
does it smell i don't know probably so
you can crack one open and annoy people
on the subway this one's coming from
ncat mao i've never been able to keep a
plant alive before even a succulent but
the new apartment screams out for plants
what are some low-maintenance
idiot-proof beginner level pet-friendly
plants don't feel bad a lot of this [ __ ]
doesn't come second nature to most
people especially since most of us don't
grow up with any gardening experience or
innate botanical knowledge i would start
off with something easy start off with
members of the plant family erasier that
would be some of the airoids there's no
schedule to watering a lot of people
mess this up there's not every three
days every four days every five days
whether you water or not is entirely
dependent on a multitude of factors that
would be uh observable in the direct
environment in this case your apartment
what's the temperature what's the
relative humidity i'm not saying you
need to go out and buy a hygrometer but
just maybe pick the plant up see if the
soil is heavy if it's got moisture in it
you know don't just throw water in there
it's you don't want the thing to rot
another thing people often do with uh
indoor plants is we forget because our
pupils can dilate we forget that the
inside of a house is often extremely
dark compared to being outside and so
what may look very bright to us even if
you got the nice painted white walls and
the big windows and whatnot even you
know still five feet from that window
it's still very dark and that plant's
light is all coming from one side so
there's an entire side of the plant
that's not getting any light at all all
right well that's all i got time for
today hopefully you learned something
pay attention look around your
environment ask some questions that's
all i got have a good rest of your day
bye